Father in heaven we thank you so much
that we've had the opportunity to review
this wonderful subject and I pray Lord
as we close up and we get ready for
Sabbath you would bless us now in the
time that we have Lord help us to cover
what needs to be covered now and I pray
for further Grace throughout the day to
get ready for your holy Sabbath day I
pray for Scott now as he's preparing for
the meeting tonight and those who are
going to come Lord we pray even now that
you prepare their hearts we ask in Jesus
name amen
okay now I've been looking kind of
through this and I'm not going to get
through everything here so I'm going to
touch on some high points
in this session
um
let's go to where were we
plagiarism charges uh we kind of looked
at that already we finished up with
Marion Davis we're going to page three
letter C we've already looked at part of
this uh plagiarism or literary borrowing
in the Bible we had the example of
Solomon we had the example of Jesus
borrowing from Solomon
Luke in his gospel starts out in Luke 1
1 talking about setting in order in
account of Jesus life death and
Resurrection I want you to note the
statement from the SDA Bible commentary
this is not Ellen White's comments
Volume 5 page 178.
it says it appears indubitable that
means unquestionable for those who don't
use that word from Luke 1 1-3 and from
the verbal parallels in the synoptic
gospels that Matthew and Luke at least
were led by the Holy Spirit to use
previously written documents in the
preparation of their Gospels
that many people should have preserved
accounts oral and written of the life
work and teachings of Jesus was only
normal and Luke States specifically that
this happened in chapter 1 verse 1. he
goes on to imply that before writing his
own account he had made research among
the sources available to him when it
says it seemed good to me also having
followed all things closely for some
time past to write an orderly account
goes on to say he pulled things together
he had different sources and he wanted
to give an accurate
presentation in the gospel and so he
would take things and and try to put
them in an orderly way so it was
sequential through the Life of Christ
um
but the point is there was literary
borrowing in the Bible it was not
uncommon it was not wrong and it was not
unethical
Ellen White's literary borrowing I want
you to notice this first statement that
Willie makes in uh a brief statement
page five
Ellen White blacked a formal education
and the Lord supplied the lack her son
Willie reported quote in her early
experience when she was sorely
distressed over the difficulty of
putting into human language the
revelations of truths that had been
imparted to her she was reminded of the
fact that an all that all wisdom and
knowledge comes from God
and she was assured that God would
bestow Grace and guidance she was told
that in the reading of religious books
and journals she would find precious
gems of Truth expressed in acceptable
language
and that she would be given help from
Heaven to recognize these to separate
them from the rubbish of error with
which she would sometimes find them
associated
it's an interesting statement from
Willie White
top of page four we went from page three
and then went up to the top of page four
so Willie says that according to mother
she uh the Lord when she was distressed
as to how with my third eighth grade
education I'm going to put all of these
fantastic Concepts into words the Lord
directed her and said I'm going to
direct you to certain places where
things are written in such a way that
you can make utilization of that now
you're maybe thinking wow this is
incredible I mean how much of this stuff
was her book how much of this made up uh
the her were her books made up of one
critic it says in number two one
prominent critic has alleged that
between 80 and 90 percent of Ellen
White's writings were borrowed from the
works of others
uh Tim Poirier in his book project
surprise reveals that with the exception
of Five Books the known documented
borrowed material that was uncredited in
her writings amounted to less than three
percent per book
and I added uncredited there
um the point is in the testimonies for
the church you don't find anything
borrowed as a rule uh when she was
trying to write Desire of Ages you'll
find things that were borrowed from
other authors the question then that you
and I would have is how much of what was
I mean how well let me put it to you
this way the next one number three the
legal findings of Vincent L ramek senior
partner of dealer ramek and white
limited a law firm specializing in
Patent Trademark and copyright law did
any of you read the handout on this okay
it's fascinating interview when you look
at it
you know people here's what the critics
say Ellen White borrowed she knew she
was stealing from other authors never
gave them credit what she did was
unethical what she did was wrong and uh
the church has never dealt with it we've
made accusations in this Evan The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church is silent
on it they don't have an answer
leave an answer after answer after
answer after answer
and they know it this is the sad part
the critics know it
uh but this is a fascinating case uh
attorney ramek was hired like I said the
other day with private funds because the
critics would have said well the church
is using it of course they're paying for
it they're going to this that and the
other private funds hired an outside Law
Firm no Seventh-day Adventist our
Adventist legal advisors our lawyers uh
Warren Johns was one of them he's the
one that kind of headed this up said
we're going to hire an outside
non-advinist Law Firm Vincent ramek was
a Catholic by profession and uh he was
the one put on the case and in uh let me
tell you what he did here
Vince ramek was basically when he went
into the case uh he didn't know anything
okay about online I told you already
that Vince ramek was given Ellen White's
books he was given all the books that
she borrowed material from
he was given the critics books the
allegations he had heard the uh I don't
I can't say that he was given their
books they may have given them to him
but here's what ramek says he basically
says look I came into the case
not knowing one thing or the other but
he says after I talked with all the
critics these were the men inside the
church that were following forward
following Walter Ray he said I actually
became biased in fact it says he says
well I came back thinking that Mrs White
was if I may use the expression that has
been used by others a literary borrower
and that she had borrowed a lot and that
she had borrowed with something less
than Candor and honesty in other words
and this was before I had delved into
her Works themselves I became actually
biased against her in the sense that I
thought she was what some people such as
her latest critic Walter Ray had alleged
guilty of plagiarism so he came in
unbiased but he said by the time I
talked to people before I even got into
the case I was actually biased against
her I said man she's guilty guilty as
Sin this is going to be an easy case
so he got in and he began to research
her writings
ramek's testimony I'm not reading all of
this to you
review the Adventist review interviewed
him and they said would you describe the
distinction that you see
let me back up
the review said so was your reading her
writings that changed your mind
he says it was reading her messages in
her writings that changed my mind and I
think there's a distinction a very
Salient difference here
review would you describe the
distinction that you see
he says I believe the critics have
missed the boat badly by focusing upon
Mrs White's writings instead of focusing
upon the messages in Mrs White's
writings
well what do you find in her messages Mr
ramek how did they affect you
ramek's response Mrs White moved me
in all Candor she moved me I'm a Roman
Catholic but Catholic Protestant
whatever she moved me and I think her
writing should move anyone unless he is
permanently biased and is unswayable
would you explain what you mean by this
remix response well a person can walk
this Earth doing good deeds and saying
to himself and maybe to others I'm a
nice person
and after a time you really come to
believe that you are
but when was the last time that you
really looked inside yourself and found
out what you were really like
now there are a lot of things that Mrs
White has put down on paper that will if
read seriously perhaps cause a person to
look inwardly honestly
and if you do the true self comes out
I think I know a little more today about
the real Vince ramek than I did before I
started reading the message of Ellen
White not simply her writings
were you surprised at this reaction
the review asked him I guess pleasantly
surprised would be a very mild
understatement
but she says some very deep things quite
frankly even if they sound as though
they've been said before quite honestly
I think I've left this task with more
than I put into it and it's simply her
messages it's simply what you receive
from reading something
it makes you believe a little more
firmly in things that you may have
believed a little bit less in the past
I'm not a religious person I'm not a
practicing Roman Catholic I was born one
but my wife happens to be a Protestant
one child is baptized Catholic one is
baptized Protestant I guess you could
say we're an ecumenical family
essentially my Outlook on anything
including this work in my daily life is
searching for God's will for me and then
I hope having the wisdom and courage to
carry it out I do have a god of my
understanding
Mrs White has made me understand him a
bit better and for that I think I'm a
better person today than when I started
this project
and I'm going to jump ahead a little bit
um
I gave you the summary of this the other
day I'm going to read it again
one thing he says is on those things she
borrowed he said Ellen White used the
writings of others but in the way she
used them she made them uniquely her own
in other words it wasn't just copied
I gave you you got the handout didn't
you on a comparison between Ellen White
and one of the authors she borrowed from
Octavius Winslow you have that you can
read that in your leisure and you can
see how she didn't copy verbatim she
used thoughts but here's what he says
She Made Them uniquely her own ethically
as well as legally and interestingly she
invariably improved that which she
selected
now you don't just take and on the
regular basis improve it if you're just
copying from somebody the whole point is
the Lord had led her just like he led
Solomon into the selection of certain
things for the purpose of enhancing the
message okay
we're going to see this in something
else in a moment now I don't know if I
mentioned this but
when they started the case they told
Vince ramek look here's what we want you
to do we want you to tell us number one
if what Ellen White did was illegal
could she be charged in a court of
justice and lose the case based on is
there a case against her number two even
if there isn't by some loophole
did she do anything unethical
that was what was asked Vince ramek okay
now his summary as I mentioned before
and I'm going to read again starting on
the bottom of the last page on this this
handout he says uh
middle column if you're looking along
with me I don't know whether she was
inspired in the theological sense I do
believe that she was highly motivated
and if God if it wasn't God who
motivated her I don't know who it could
have been
but I get that simply from her writings
I was not there when she wrote and I
suppose a few of the critics were either
I have a feeling that unless you had
some type of motivation you simply could
not deliver in Words with that which I
have received from her writings now I
personally could not be disturbed by the
thought that God may have inspired her
to select something from a certain book
and if God inspired her select something
uh that was written by better by someone
else then she could have written it I'm
sorry let me start if God inspired her
select to select that something that was
written by some
boy I pause for a minute here
and take a deep breath
now I personally could not be disturbed
by the thought that God may have
inspired her to select something from a
different book and if God inspired her
to select something that was written
better by someone else than she could
have written it herself so what
actually in the final analysis I think
it all comes down to the question of
faith and for myself I have no trouble
in accepting what she wrote as a matter
of Faith the bottom line is what really
counts is the message of Mrs White not
merely the mechanical writings words
causes sentences of Mrs White the
theologians I am told distinguish here
between verbal inspiration and plenary
inspiration too many of the critics have
missed the boat altogether and it's too
bad too I personally have been moved
deeply moved by those writings I have
been changed by them I think I'm a
better man today because of them and I
wish the critics could discover that
so the review finishes the question
attorney ramek how would you sum up the
legal case against Ellen White as far as
charges of plagiers and piracy and
copyright infringement are concerned
ramek says if I had been involved in
such a legal case I would much rather
appear as defense counsel for the
prosecution there simply is no case now
to beat this dead horse it doesn't make
sense we've covered it we've looked at
it I've got more things here in the
handouts but the reality is
the Adventist Church got a private Law
Firm could out did Ellen might do
anything illegal no it's been solved
we've answered the question unethical no
it's been solved in a non-practising
Catholic really a non-Christian man
Outsider but if he had any any direction
in his Christianity it would have been
Catholic who read through the whole
great controversy that's the only book
he read all the way through
and learned that the Antichrist is the
Catholic Church still could say I'm a
changed man and if the critics would
just focus on the message of her books
instead of picking nitpicking all these
things to death they'd be better people
because of it
what more do we need
um I want to go to letter e and just
note some of these statements here
Ecclesiastes 1 9
says that there's nothing new Under the
Sun and there's some statements here
that I think are really good on this
um I like number two Roger made
this statement a prophet's words are not
true because a prophet says them
the prophet says them because they are
true
okay
review and Herald of July 16 1889 Ellen
White says Christ came to represent the
father to the world he was the
originator of Truth
but when he came he found that gems of
Truth had been obscured by tradition and
heresy he came to sweep away false
Doctrine and to place the gems of Truth
in the new setting of The Gospel
she says Christ himself came and he took
things that were all buried up by the
rubbish of uh tradition like the Sabbath
and he pulled it out and he put it in a
new setting
he left the rubbish behind and he picked
a piece of Truth out
that's what the Lord did through through
Ellen White as she found things in other
places
which was a very small portion of what
she wrote most of what she wrote was her
own but she did take things
following just basically what we read
there Jesus himself did it I want you to
see this next statement number four
suppose for example now let me give you
the background here and it's at the end
of the paragraph Heman Humphrey
president of Amherst College in the
preface of John Harris biography of
Jesus called the great teacher which was
published in 1835. when Ellen White was
about eight years old
said the following this is the preface
to a book on the Life of Christ by this
man that was written when Ellen White
was eight years old she'd not been
called to the office of profit yet so
Ellen might isn't even in the picture
here
suppose he says for example
an inspired Prophet were now to appear
in the church to add a supplement to the
canonical books
now that's amazing isn't it there's no
chance of this this is 1835. this man
doesn't know what he said I mean there's
no there's no Ellen White in the whole
picture but he's saying what if what if
God were to do this by chance
an inspired Prophet were to appear in
the church to add a supplement to the
canonical books what a babble of
opinions would he find on almost every
theological subject
and how highly probable it is that his
ministry would consist or seem to
consist in a mere selection and
ratification of such of these opinions
as accorded with the mind of God
absolute originality would seem to be
almost impossible the inventive mind of
man has already bodied forth speculative
opinions in almost every conceivable
form for stalling and robbing the future
we're turning the page
number five
top of the page
robbing the future of its Fair
proportion of Novelties and leaving
little more even to a Divine messenger
than the office of taking some of these
opinions and impressing them with the
Seal of Heaven in other words there
everything's already been written he
says what would a prophet do if a
prophet came today but take from those
things that have already been written
and try to arrange him and pull the
truth out of the error that's what this
man's saying
and that's exactly what we find in the
spirit of Prophecy the next statement
review and Herald January 7 1890 says
Patriarchs and Prophets and apostles
spoke as they were moved upon by the
Holy Ghost and they plainly stated what
they spoke not by their own power nor in
their own name
they desired that no credit might be
ascribed to them that no one might
regard them as The Originators of
anything whereof they might Glory Christ
is the author of all truth
now if Christ inspired some truth
somewhere is it his prerogative to
direct you to that truth
boastful and egotistical is the man or
woman who claims truth is their own
amen look at the last one there in that
section an illustration was given me she
says of a tree Laden with beautiful
fruit
I was shown Fannie Fanny Bolton was one
of Ellen White's literary assistants she
later claimed to have written steps to
Christ and I was talking to some here
during the break what they don't tell
you on the websites is that Fanny Bolton
was in the Kalamazoo state mental
hospital for a couple times because like
I said she had issues and um they don't
tell you that on the website
you know they just say well Fanny Bolton
says no she she wrote the book steps to
Christ and this is circulated among
Adventists but
um
that's been disproven and it's you can
read more about it in the book Ellen
White commenting on this she has this
illustration in vision
she saw this tree full of beautiful
fruit I was shown Fanny Gathering the
fruit some ripe the best
and some unripe she put it in her apron
and said this is mine it is mine
I said Fanny you are certainly claiming
that which is not yours that fruit
belongs to that tree
anyone May pluck and enjoy it but it
God is the originator of Truth and
that's the point that's being made there
uh one thing I mentioned I think I
mentioned before maybe I didn't is that
you know Ellen White the books that she
borrowed from like Coney Baron Hassan is
it a life of Paul I think that that
there's there they wrote on the life of
Paul
um there are a couple books that she
brought anyway Ellen White recommended
the books that she borrowed from that's
not a that's not a smart idea for a
plagiarist
to recommend and say yeah I wrote this
book by the way why don't you read this
one that's where I borrowed it over no I
mean evidently she had nothing to hide
you follow that and that's what Vince
ramek said hey according to all the laws
in her date she was doing nothing that
all the other authors weren't doing it
was no big deal but you understand again
with the person with a verbal
inspiration mindset now we've got
problems because how can you be a verbal
inspiration how could how can you be a
prophet if you've gotten something and
you put down something that was somebody
else had put down somewhere
do you follow that does anybody have
questions on this plagiarism issue
from what we've covered here
okay
these are I'm not going to go into some
of the other uh those that last section
there uh letter c
inside the church Luke 13 33 says can it
be that a prophet should perish outside
Jerusalem
interesting text
could it be Jesus said that a prophet
should perish outside Jerusalem of
course not
it's a rhetorical question obviously
negative answer of course not why would
a prophet perish outside Jerusalem why
would he ask why would he say such a
thing like that could it be that a
prophet could perish outside Jerusalem
what do you think the point is
why not
they don't interest they have no
interest in it they don't believe in
prophets they don't follow prophets the
people that get fired up about profits
are the people that recognize that a
prophet means Authority that they don't
want to be under and by their profession
to be a Christian they should be under
even now now listen to me here even the
critics outside the church
almost every one of them
began inside the church
their disgruntled Adventists disgruntled
pastors disgruntled teachers disgruntled
Adventists and I've asked people before
take follow me for a minute
those of you you know if you God forbid
that this would happen but if those of
you were married had a terrible nasty
divorce
it was vicious and and and there was a
lot of just a lot of hatred in there
would you down the road when when
somebody asked you for a character
reference say yeah talk to my ex about
that
yes or no
yeah but we're going to go we want to
find out about Ellen White let's go talk
to the disgruntled Adventist pastors who
have an ax to grind
you follow the you call do you see what
I'm going where we're going with that if
you're going to ask somebody yeah I want
a good unbiased opinion so I'm going to
go to the person who has an ax to grind
against the church
yeah that makes sense
are you with me on that
where we get more of this heat is from
the inside of the church Jesus point was
there was never the prophets were never
uh the prophets never perished outside
Jerusalem it's only when the saints got
mad at the prophet because the people
outside okay whatever you say it's your
opinion they don't care it's the people
inside who profess to follow the prophet
that have the issue with the prophet
under there number one notice what it
says people who don't generally believe
in God don't really care much about what
a prophet has to say people in general
will not be annoyed at your personal
choices for nutrition and Optimal Health
for example however it's an entirely
should have been a period there however
it's an entirely different story with
the Saints why because there's Authority
behind the prophet and good health moves
from what's good for you
two
Christian Duty
consider Oprah's diet compared to yours
and mine Oprah Winfrey goes on a diet
she's following she goes on this good
plant-based diet and everybody's like
whoa you go girl look at Oprah yeah and
you and I talk about a vegetarian diet
in the church and people say you're
trying to bring us under all those Rules
by Ellen White
what's up with that
you know it's okay for the people in the
world and so because it's it's okay for
you it's okay for you you know that's
your big that's your deal and everything
else and
but when when when you add see what
happens is when it becomes an issue of
authority
it's not even so much the issue of diet
or or whatever it may happen to be it's
that Humanity the carnal heart
is restless under restraint
we don't like to be told what to do
do we no
no the battle with self
Ellen White says is the greatest battle
that will ever be fought
and if you're not fighting that battle
daily
you need to recommit your life to Christ
that's the Christian walk
we don't like to be in subjection to
somebody we don't like Authority it's
one thing to have an option that I'm oh
yeah I'm gonna I I'm gonna eat healthy
or you know no I just really don't go
for that I just like junk food all the
time
or
there's a difference between that and
feeling that it's a Christian Duty I'm
gonna I'm gonna add this for you here
today just to
to give you uh something to think about
those of you who have Ellen White CD-ROM
or will get on the internet and you can
search in through her writings
that's everybody pretty much by the way
because you have access here do a little
search on these words
I'm going to write them up here for you
the
and inclination
and you will find now there's this
theory that goes around today with
Christianity that says we shouldn't
really do anything as Christians until
we really feel like doing it in other
words if there's a Christian Duty like
going out on a Bible study well if you
go out on the Bible study when you don't
want to go that's legalism
you know the gospel is you'll want to do
it
well
that's kind of true
part of you is going to want to do it
when you're converted part of you wants
to do it but the Bible says the flesh
lasts against the spirit and the spirit
against the Flesh and the two are at
odds they're contrary to one another so
that you don't do the things that you
want to do so battle in Romans 7. you
see Duty and Incarnation and Ellen White
says this
in essence in statement after statement
that you and I as Christians should
follow Duty
and not inclination
we should follow Duty and not
inclination what's inclination
what you want to do what you're inclined
to do
and there are times when you and I know
what's right but we don't feel like
doing it
right
and I want to tell you something
Brothers and Sisters I Don't Think Jesus
wanted to go to the cross
and I believe I have good Bible reason
for that because Jesus prayed three
times in the garden father
if there's any way
take this cup from me
if there's any other way I don't want to
go through with this
but nevertheless not my will but thy
will be done
it's not legalism to follow Christian
Duty
we have a nature that's going to fight
us to the death
and by God's grace the nature dies
we're crucified with Christ but there
are going to be times in your Christian
experience where you follow Duty and not
inclination
um
and the fact is a lot of that you know
people talk about this issue of Duty we
don't like it the Saints don't like it a
lot of times
don't tell me about Duty that's
illegalism like I said there was a man
minister in uh
I think it was in Sweden I'm not sure
Stockholm Sweden I'm pretty sure his
name was Madison
uh m-a-t-t-e-s-o-n if you want to look
it up and sister white said to brother
man brother Madison Ellen White went
over there to preach and brother Madison
told sister white you know what the
people over here they're kind of
restless I think they'd I think they'd
be much more
um
uh open
if you would speak less about Duty and
more about the love of Jesus
and alamite says I told Brother Madison
if that's your work go ahead and do it
but that's not the work God's called me
to do God knows what these people need
and I'm going to preach what he gives me
to preach and she says I spoke on Isaiah
58 and I didn't round the corners at all
that means the corners are Sharp
I didn't round it off I told him what
the Lord told me to tell him Duty
Oh Ellen White was legalistic they say
you need to understand that there's
nothing wrong with Christian Duty
you know there are things that I do as a
pastor that I don't I'm not inclined to
do
and and the only reason I do it
the only reason I follow that Duty
is because I love the Lord who gave me
gave himself for me
but that doesn't make me
more inclined but it does motivate me
the love of Christ compels us amen
inside the church
we don't have a whole lot of time here
um
we've looked at some of these already so
I'm not going to spend time with this uh
Satan's last deception is making of none
affected testimonies there's some things
you can look at there
uh opinion versus inspiration Jeremiah
29 27 essentially they said hey we don't
need to hear it Jeremiah has made
himself a prophet is what it says in
Jeremiah 29 27. they say the same things
about Ellen White in the church well
that's alamite's opinion
read some of these things when you have
time to read them
I like the statement there on 2B on page
seven 2B on page seven from third
selected messages page 60 note except
this is a note that's found in through
selected messages except for that this
isn't Ellen White by the way uh this is
a comment you know because she's talking
about opinion Etc except for that which
is in the nature of everyday matters or
biographical
that which Mrs White set forth before
the people was based upon the Visions
given her whether or not she used the
term I saw
she in her day and we today draw the
line not between the books and letters
Etc but between the sacred and the
common no one need be confused
okay you know what's inspired what's not
inspired
there's a there's the there's a
statement to help you understand not
between the book between the sacred and
common we don't need to worry about
whether it's books or books and letters
that which she set forth except for
everyday matters you know a letter dear
Emma how are you doing today you know
Etc and give it to the grocery list Etc
not inspired stuff when she gave
spiritual counsel she gave it as a
prophet in one place Ellen White says I
dare not speak a word you know on a
subject that I haven't received light
from sometimes people ask her opinion on
something sister white would you give me
your opinion she says I don't have any
light on that I don't I don't dare give
my opinion is people going to say the
prophet said it hmm
and you've got that in that handout I
gave you on the authority of Ellen White
there's things in there about that
um
somebody had asked about the idea of
compilations talk let me talk about that
for a minute a compilation
some people really are hard on
compilations I love compilations
you just gotta understand a compilation
for what it is
you read the book evangelism it's a
compilation well I don't have time how
many of you have the book evangelism is
that a required book for this course
should be that book's like this thick
what would happen if you try to compile
every one of those things those articles
in their entirety that she wrote from in
the book evangelism you know you never
get through it
a a compilation is like an index
and especially today with a CD-ROM and
everything else you've got full access
to her writings understand when you read
something in a compilation that you're
getting a paragraph it may be uh or or
less
maybe she wrote a letter to somebody and
in the midst of the context of that
letter that you don't have you've got
this statement okay
take it for what it is if you say I
don't understand that that doesn't then
type it in and go find some more
writings on that subject it's a
reference book The book's Adventist home
the book Child Guidance if you want to
get more information look up the article
it's written in get the context of it
don't jump to conclusions without the
context but overall even even then
overall like an Adventist home you have
a a section on discipline well you have
these statements out of context
deliberately
but there's plenty of them you ought to
be able to get some context by the time
you go through that okay so but
understanding compilation for what it is
Ellen White recommended after she died
that her books would be continue to
circulate and the compilations would be
made
so that it would keep interest
before the people you know
you know how we are oh is that a new one
most of us haven't read hardly anything
else why it's written but we're like oh
oh hey look this is a new book
so Dr Pittman probably talked about that
he's talked about that before we just
love the word new you put new in front
of anything and everybody's oh look this
is new
so compilations that's compilations were
drawn together on certain subjects it's
a reference material in a subject like
Christian Living the Adventist home like
raising your children and Child Guidance
like evangelism and evangelism like
councils and diets and Foods obviously
on health especially diet
um
if you want more understand that it's
not there in context do you follow what
I said there are you with me on that yes
yes Maria you got a question mark on
your head
laughs
did you have a question on anything okay
I just want to make sure it wasn't about
to this next one here I'm going to touch
on this and then
uh the the issue of eight to element
changing after 1888 I have had people
tell me I had a conference president
tell me this
he said well we know Sister white
changed her viewpoints after 1888 you
know and so uh you know and here's
here's why they say it let me tell you
I'll just be straight with you why they
say that
the reason they say that is because the
testimonies for the church volumes one
through nine
were mostly compiled prior to 1888 at
least a half of them and the bigger
volumes they can't have a lot of
straight testimony and they say well you
know that wasn't very kind and loving
and then after we're 1888 Elm white
understood the gospel better and then
she got kind and loving on us you know
and then that's you know so she changed
her theology
now the statement there that you find
underneath I want you to know what
element says during 1888 conference
Wagner and Jones were presenting the
message of righteousness by faith she
said I've had the question asked what do
you think of the light these men have
been presenting or are presenting A.T
Jones and E.J Wagner why I've been
presenting it to you for what
the last 45 years when was it written
1889 uh spect 45 years from that
when's what what does it bring it to
1844 when did she receive her first
vision
okay so I've been presenting it too for
the last 45 years she says the matchless
charms of Christ this is what I've been
trying to present before your minds
now this is what uh Tim Poirier said in
a letter I sent off to the white estate
I said I want you to give me uh somebody
I just want you to see your take on this
thing about her her writings after 1888.
um
Tim Boyer said
one with fine statements just as
forceful on the place of Law and
obedience post 1888 and statements that
up left the merits of Christ
righteousness as our only hope and
Assurance just as strongly prior to
1888. this is not to say that one won't
find a greater emphasis in her writings
and speaking on the Life of Christ in
the 1890s due largely to that to the
years she spent in Australia expanding
her two volume Life of Christ series
into what will become Desire of Ages
well that was on her mind so obviously
now she's gotten a new view on that but
not a different view he goes on to say
into what would become sorry and what
would become Desire of Ages Christ
object lessons amount of blessings
additionally we have probably 75 percent
more literary output after 1888 at least
in terms of her published articles in
other words she wrote more later in her
life
so he says so dividing her writing into
pre-post 1888 will tend to give
distorted results in terms of the total
quantity of statements on these themes
in other words if you take virtually any
statement from Ellen White the chances
are much greater that it will date after
1888. yeah
point is she didn't change her theology
over the course of time
uh you know and again the reason people
pick at that is they're looking for a
loophole
they're looking for a loophole so that
they can discredit Ellen White they read
those statements that cut across their
path the way that they do things and
they say oh well this is in the
testimonies this is written before 1888
before Ellen White got to really view a
true view of the Gospel so there's no
there's no mayor